so today I'm going to describe some new
tools for estimating treatment effects
in the presence of high dimensional or
nonparametric nuisance and this is
pretty new work I'd love to get your
feedback and I'd love to get your
perspective on anything I talked about
today and this project came out of a
conversation that I had with vasila
circus Vasilisa is a colleague of mine
at Microsoft Research he studies machine
learning and economics and I'll go to
that game theory and the conversation
went a little bit like this one day came
over to me and said Lester I love double
machine learning and I said what and he
said it's a tool for accurately
estimating treatment effects in the
presence of many potential confounders I
said I have no idea what you're talking
about
so he said okay okay let me give you an
example so this is the example that he
gave and it's estimating price
elasticity of the man that is estimating
how the man changes when price changes
and so this sort of thing certainly
comes up if you work at a tech company
like Microsoft it also comes up if your
food distributor and you want to know
how to price different products and it
even comes up if you work for the World
Health Organization of the World Bank
and you're interested in the effect of
attacks on tobacco consumption on
purchasing cigarettes so how do you go
about doing this estimation well
typically you collect some data you know
data involving prices that were set and
amount the amount of demand that
responded to those prices and so you
might have a data set like this is a
pretty small data set but it's a data
set and so what's the first thing you
might do well you say okay well if I
want to predict elasticity I should just
regress log demand on to log price so
here's our regression model Y is log
demand t is the log price the treatment
in this experiment and the coefficient
that relates them is going to be the
elasticity ideally and so you might just
say I'll just do an ordinarily squares
regression and I'll get a best fit and
that will be my last to city so what
happens in this example if we do that
well here's your best fit line and if
you read off the slope of this best fit
line it tells you that increasing price
increases demand and that seems
problematic
it doesn't quite jibe with our intuition
for how demand and price work and so
what happened here well what happened is
that like in most pricing problems
actually there's some degree of
seasonality so these points that are
collected up here are actually from the
winter where demand is higher and often
increases in the winter due to big
holidays like Christmas and Black Friday
if you consider that to be a holiday and
the points down here we're in fact
collected in the summer and so what
happens well here we have a case where
we all actually have the price affecting
the demand we actually have the demand
act affecting the price so everyone
knows that demand is going to go up in
the winter and they've adjusted prices
accordingly to account for that
so that's a problem and this is a
problem from essentially our regression
model and so how could we fix this issue
how can we account for the fact that we
have this seasonality
well one pretty easy way is just to
introduce a confounder the season as a
variable into our Russian model so now I
have an indicator variable this extra co
variate x it also has a coefficient and
now I've accounted for that potential
confound something that affects both
price and demand that I didn't that I
didn't account for before okay so now
what happens if I run rerun my
regression well then I get something
like this because the indicator I can
have a split point and the coefficient
the elasticity coefficient that if it is
actually pretty reasonable in this case
it's a perfect fit to my data but of
course this is a very artificial data
set ok with this this you can take my
word for this fixed in this particular
problem but in this case we're only
dealing with a single confounder in an
artificial data set what if there are
hundreds of confounders what if there
are thousands of confounders and
actually that's this typical case these
days on top of seasonality is it winter
or summer we care about the time of day
we care about the day of the week we
care about the month we observe purchase
histories past purchase histories from
customers if ever a business we observed
your browsing history if we're
essentially any website that you use we
had taken to account other product
prices and we care about how those
impact price elasticity
where you take into account demographics
we might even take into account the
weather and these are all things that we
routinely collect that's readily
available and it's likely that at least
some of it does impact both the the
price and the demand that there'll be
some of these things are likely
confounders so how do we deal with all
of those things and this is the question
that bacillus was posing to me this is
the this is why this example came up so
how do we deal with all of those things
simultaneously well okay so here's one
option here's what you may call the
classical option and we could estimate
the effect of all of the potential
confounders really well so that's option
one so here again is our regression
model we have our we have our log demand
Y we have our log price T that's we care
about the elasticity but then now we
have all of these other confounders
that's this whole of vector X and they
have some effect on the potential come
if some effect on the the log demand
we'll call that F 0 this is some
function relating the confounders to the
outcome that we don't know but in some
sense we have to care about because it
affects the answer okay so what we know
from just standard asymptotics is that
if we could estimate f 0 this nuisance
function at an end to the minus 1/2 rate
then we can also get a good estimate of
theta 0 so it's all we have to do all
we've to do is estimate all the effects
really well and we'll get a good
estimate of the elasticity that seems
kind of problematic typically accurate
Newton's estimates are unavailable if F
0 is high dimensional it was a linear
and high dimensional or if it's a
nonparametric so what else can we do
well this is where that double machine
learning comes back into place this is
an idea do the chair know Zhukov and
colleagues although it built on a lot of
pass work of a similar flavor and the
idea is that we can get a somewhat poor
estimate of the nuisance function f 0
and then a count for that so when we
estimate theta 0 we're going to do it in
two stages so first we're gonna estimate
F 0 then we decimate theta 0 we're gonna
do it in a way that's somewhat robust to
errors in that first stage so we're
going to use what's called a name and
orthogonal estimator
to be robust to the errors in our
estimate of the new sense okay so what
does that buy us well specifically what
their theory says is that an end to the
minus 1/4 estimate of F zero is
sufficient to get a square root and
consistent estimate of treatment effect
of your elasticity in this case so
that's good that's a pretty big gain we
don't need to get we don't need to we're
not demanding the same level of quality
from our nuisance estimates as we word
from our the estimate that we cared
about the target parameter but I think
it also raises a lot of questions so for
one you know why n to the minus 1/4
where does that come from can you relax
that what can you relax that and how can
you relax that so these are all the
sorts of questions that I want to deal
with today yeah sorry for the night
question yeah why restrict yourself to
this regression model what if you used a
tree based model okay so I didn't even
explain what I meant by machine learning
and this double machine learnings that's
a great question so the regression model
so if there's in in this model we only
have one primer that we care about theta
zero and so in some sense I mean you
could use a tree based method but you
know aggression if I if I had a good
estimate of f zero then doing just
something like linear regression it
would work very well um for the smaller
you could change you could change the
model slightly to account for other
relationships between T and Y but where
the machine learning comes into play
here is that you're gonna use your
favorite machine learning methods to get
an estimate of this f0 so those could be
tree based methods that could be neural
networks whatever you want and the idea
is that if you can get a good estimate
in terms of prediction error zero then
you can also get a good estimate theta
zero and I think you're asking you know
why is the relationship between T and y
so constrained in a lot of cases it's
because T is just a binary outcome
anyway and so this is as general as
you're going to get you know just
learning one parameter which is if you
if you are treated then there's this
effect on the log demand and if you're
not treated you haven't another effect
but mostly just for today just for the
simplicity of presentation nothing we're
doing relies particularly on this model
I'll present enough I'll presented
number specializations of a results in
the setting but we're actually gonna be
working in a general setting of
generalized methods a method of moments
what I really want to highlight about
the relationship between theta 0 and F 0
here is that often the parameter that
you care about the relationship you care
about is something that's intrinsically
low dimensional something that's pretty
simple and the thing that you don't know
is much more complex and so in those
sorts of cases you want to get really
good estimates of the simple thing
without having to get really a good
estimates a bit less thing you're not
worried about the zero being zero
sufficiently complex model that's zero
well it could and that's often what you
often you what you're doing is something
about it's something like a test so your
dream has four Association condition on
everything else that I've tried to you
know condition all those confounders
does it still make a difference and if
it doesn't it means your treatment
didn't really matter
sorry I'm I'm worried but that's that's
important that is something that we care
about
okay so what are we going to do in this
talk I'm going to give you a framework
for a generalization of this naming
orthogonal estimation so it's a
orthogonality and roughly what you get
from this is that n to the minus 1 over
2k plus 2 consistency for your inner
sense estimates implies root and
consistency for your target parameter so
by employing this higher note order
notion of robustness you can actually do
a worse job at estimating the nuisance
and still get a good estimate of your
target then we'll talk about when these
kate order orthogonal moments actually
exist as for that I'm going to focus on
the partially a linear regression model
that's common and causal inference and
give you a characterization of this so
cases where this these moments don't
exist and also where they do exist and
where they do exist I'll give you some
explicit construction of second-order
orthogonal moments and show you how they
work in practice
okay so I need to explain a lot of
things for that what's let's get a bit
more abstract so this is the general
problem we're trying to solve an
estimation with nuisance problem there's
a target parameter theta it's an R to
the D these could think of these as the
elasticity's there's some unknown new
sis functions that also impact the
outcome of interest and we're going to
try to estimate the target parameters
given independent replicates of a data
vector in this case I have a data set of
size 2n that's 2n because I'm going to
split it in half at some point so let's
keep it to around and to give you an
example what this data vector might look
like this is going to be a running
example throughout the talk I'd like to
consider this what's called a partially
linear regression model so T here
represents a treatment or policy that's
applied so you could think about it as
the log price in our example y is going
to be an outcome of interest the log
demand and X is going to be a vector of
associated covariates like seasonality
or other potential confounders that
could impact both the treatment and the
outcome and under the partially linear
regression model all these variables
satisfy the following relationship so we
have essentially two equations one looks
very much like the one I've been
displaying to you so the the linear part
is the relationship between T and Y the
partially part is this that 0 which is
not necessarily linear and there's a
second equation that governs how the
treatment is impacted by the different
confounders so again there's a nuisance
function so the nuisance functions here
are F 0 and G 0 and the parameter you
care about is David 0
Absalon a knitter just noise variables
in the month okay so come back to this
model again and again but what else do
we how are we actually going to go about
estimating our target parameters so
we're going to use what you could call
two-stage z estimation or two stage
method of moments and so to do this
we're going we need some moment
functions m that identify the target
parameter and so identify in the
following way it should be the case that
when so you're okay M is a function of
your data z as a function of your target
parameter theta zero and it's a function
of the output of your nuisance h0 and it
should be the case that on average when
theta zero is plugged into M the value
is zero so it's mean zero when theta
zero is plugged in conditioned on X your
covariance and you also want it to not
be mean zero when theta is not equal to
the truth this is the identification
part okay sir this conditionally means
you're a moment function at the truth
and how do we go about doing estimation
so we're going to do so first just an
example in our PLR model typical example
of a moment function would be just the
score function that you get from a
linear from ordinary least-squares so if
I already knew the nuisance f zero and I
want to estimate theta in the plra model
I might just do it a least squares
regression this is the derivative of the
least squares objective
setting that equal to zero on average is
what you do to solve a squares problem
okay so that's the PLR model example
actually it's just worth saying that
this is one moment function for this
problem a big focus of the talk will
actually be on constructing better
moment functions for this problem and
have better robustness properties in
this
okay so to stage the estimation with
sample splitting how does this work
so in stage one we're going to estimate
the new sense however we like so we will
use our favorite machine learning
methods some nonparametric regression
and some high dimensional regression
somehow we're going to get back some
estimates H hat of the nuisance h0 for
this we're going to use the second half
of our data so data points n plus 1 up
through to n now to fit theta we're
going to plug H hat into the moment
function and then we're just going to
solve and then we're going to do the
estimation we're going to finally find
the value of theta that sets the sample
mean equal to zero this is the sample
mean of the moment function equal to 0
so standard C estimation
it's two-stage because we had two we
didn't know what the nuisance was ahead
of time so we plugged in an estimate of
it
this is called the sample splitting
approach to two stages of estimation
because we were using the first half of
the sample to estimate H hat and we're
using the second half to do this to find
theta to find the final estimate of
theta which I'll call theta hat SS for
samples
okay so there's some drawbacks to using
sample splitting in this way it's
statistically inefficient often what's
impacted is the first stage because
that's usually the harder part of it I
mean the second part the problem is
pretty easy and in the PLR model we're
fitting one parameter that's a pretty
easy thing but the first part is
impacted by using much less data so how
do we deal with that well there's a
second version of this two-stage the
estimation that cherno zhukov it all
advocate in their double machine
learning paper which is called cross
fitting and the idea is that you split
your data into K batches you fit K
different estimates of your nuisance
parameters so each one with hope with
holding the data from one batch so I'll
call the batches I 1 through I K so it's
K different capital k different
estimates H hat k and then when I choose
my final parameter I plug in the the
nuisance function estimate that is from
that did not use the fold that my data
point is coming from for every data
point Z txt I'm only using the estimate
that was based on other data independent
data in this case because the points of
the data points are iid and roughly
because a lot of the analysis is going
to be asymptotic and we have
asymptotically linear statistics this
actually mitigates the effects of sample
splitting and we regain the efficiency
that was lost
yeah like by analogy to like the biasing
is there a way to see why here at sample
the independence is necessary but the
biasing it wasn't that's not necessarily
the road at all you could use other
arguments just directly argue about
training area but this just work this
works a lot better in practice so yeah
if you compared the sample splitting
version to this version to a version
where you just use the same data in both
on both iterations this works much much
better but the other ones also analyzed
the other ones also analyzable and
asymptotically they're all good yeah and
there so I think there's some very close
parallels between this double machine
learning literature and the device lots
of literature so I'll come back to that
at the very end
okay so now we have our estimators theta
hat CF as the CrossFitting
they do have SS as sample splitting our
goal is going to be us to establish root
n asymptotic normality
of these estimators so I want route
inconsistency and I want them to be
asymptotically normal estimates this
will allow us to do absentee ballot
hypothesis testing for instance
Association testing conditions uncle
Eretz and also to establish
asymptotically valid confidence
intervals okay so the real question is
when can I get this and in particular
what moments do I need to use to achieve
this well let's start with what the
double machine learning literature
suggests which is first order of thought
idle moments or what you might call
naman orthogonal moments the idea is
that on top of having your moment
function be mean zero you want it to be
you want its gradient with respect to
the nuisance parameters to also beat me
and zero all right that's what this
definition says the gradient respect to
the nuisance parameters is also main
zero this is a principle that actually
dates back to the early work of namin
who is developing better unbiased tests
in the presence of nuisance although it
you know it's had several developments
since that point and essentially what it
does is it grants first-order
insensitivity to errors in the nuisance
if you do a Taylor expansion of your
moment function around the nuisance
around your plug in estimate of the
nuisance the first order terms just go
to 0 R 0 on average and so now the error
is actually dominated by a second and
higher order terms and that's the value
that you're getting from your using into
first order of thought mental moments
now interestingly this property is not
satisfied by the standard moments that
you'd get out of least squares and when
we said I shared with you before but it
is satisfied by and sorry this is under
the PLR model so I'll keep coming back
to that examples under the PLR model
it's not satisfied by the moments I
shared with you before but it is
satisfied with these modified moments
that are both discussed in the trainer's
of golf paper but have much longer
history
okay and so the main result of cheddar
Zhukov at all and the setting is that if
I can get end to the minus 1/4 estimates
of the nuisance and I use first order of
thought finality for my moments then I
get rude and asymptotic normality so
instead of having to you know fit the
perimeter as well well being a true
dendrites I only need n to the minus 1/4
rates and life is still good
so you might ask then oh yeah no Jew
also need to ask me here you also need
to estimate G so this is this is end of
the minus 1/4 estimate so whenever I say
H it's all the nuisance and now the
nuisance is both F and G
okay so you might wonder how do we go
beyond that and it seems like there's a
natural way to iterate this process we
just got rid of the first order moment
for the first order Taylor expansion
terms let's just get rid of more terms
and so that's what we're going to call K
orthogonality so you want your moment
function to not just have not to not
just be mean zero and have greet it
means zero we want higher order
differentials to also be named zero so
we're using the differential operator
simply we're saying partial derivatives
of order K and below our zero on average
that's what Kate or orthogonality is and
again the intuition is that we want to
kill terms in a Taylor expansion around
the true value of a new sex
okay so what does this buy us well
here's a result from our work and it
says that if you use K orthogonality and
you have your standard identify about
identify ability and regularity
assumptions about your moments then end
to the minus 1 over 2k plus 2 estimates
of your nuisance is division
so there are a few things unpack here
first you get rude and asymptotic
normality I've given you an expression
for the covariance matrix so it depends
on a couple of properties of your moment
function it depends on the covariance of
your moment function and also on the
inverse of the gradient of your moment
function with respect to theta and we'll
come back to that later because it'll
turn out that when these moments don't
exist or when useful moments don't exist
it's stupid because this value is zero
and hence your asymptotic covariance
would be okay we'll come back to that
there are a couple of just remarks to
make so I've I've said that you want
every nuisance function to have this
rate of decay technically the analysis
only requires that products of the
nuisance functions have to decay so if
you've estimate one really well you can
afford to estimate another one more
poorly it's kind of like double
robustness type property
you can prove similar results for
non-uniform orthogonalize if you don't
actually need all of your second order
moments to be orthogonal you could just
pick and choose and you'll still get
some benefits from that
and finally what I mean what's worth
highlighting about the result is this
holds the promise of coping with more
complex nuisance functions with less
data but of course that's only a useful
promise if these moments actually exist
so how do we construct K orthogonal
moments in practice
or actually here's a more basic question
can we construct K orthogonal moments in
practice and here's a I just remind you
this is our partially linear regression
model again so we're going to focus in
on this model and try to characterize K
orthogonality in this setting or at
least two orthogonal in this setting and
it turns out that the answer is
sometimes and in particular if your if
your treatment residual in that second
equation the ADA is Gaussian technically
conditionally Gaussian given X but if
it's a Gaussian then there's no two
orthogonal moment that will yield root
and consistency
okay and so you can actually prove that
yeah yeah
it it isn't it isn't so it depends on M
and the M has to satisfy your K
orthogonality property and so different
you're gonna have to choose a different
M for each k typically yeah and so the
result of that and this is worth
mentioning is that essentially what
you're doing by introducing this
orthogonal is reducing bias but you're
gonna pay for it invariant so typically
your variance is going to go up but
you're also going to be able to handle
more complex settings that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to deal with so there's
a bias variance trade-off there that's a
that's great so they're there I think
we'd have to say something a bit more
explicit about exactly what moments are
using and if there is you know and
explicit so you might think given and
believe this is true like given a you
know K minus 1 orthogonal moment there
is a natural K orthogonal moment and
then you'd be able to trace out that up
that variance with K but this is really
saying pick any your pick your favorite
K orthogonal moment of any type at any
point and this is what your question
will look like so it's hard to do that
comparison without being more explicit
okay so right alright we had this
negative result an i/o set okay so we
use to show this we use Stein's lemma
and so what this lets us which is
essentially just integration by parts so
this less to show that if your two
orthogonal then this derivative with
respect to theta of M is also going to
be zero while your treatment residual is
Gaussian which means that you're if you
were a root inconsistent you'd have
infinite variance then infinite
asymptotic variance which means that you
have a very useless
that's bad but in our pricing setting
that motivated all this non-gaussian
residuals are actually typical so a
typical sort of pricing setting scheme
is that you have a baseline price
baseline log price and you introduce
random discounts like 10% off 25% off
through Sunday these are actually
discrete perturbations of your baseline
price and they're decidedly non Gaussian
so there's still hope for getting gains
out of our second or higher order of
thought venality so we're going to come
back to this question again of you know
how do we actually construct or yeah how
do we actually construct care without in
a moment to when we can and what we
learn from the last slide is that if we
want to do this we'll have to exploit
non-gaussian 'ti somehow here's one
characterization of Gaussian I take it
is Gaussian so a Gaussian distribution
is defined by its moments and the
moments satisfy this particular
condition so it is conditionally
Gaussian given X if and only if it
satisfies these moment relationships for
all integers n are at all integers are
so what we're going to do is try to
exploit the violation of one of these
conditions and construct moments that
work well when when that condition is
violated so here's the result
if you don't satisfy this condition for
some R and hence you're not Gaussian but
this in a particular way you're not
gotten this particular way and if I know
essentially your art the art moment of
ADA then the following moments are two
orthogonal
this is what they look like they're a
couple things worth noting about this
first
I've actually introduced another
nuisance function so before we had f ng
q is a linear combination of F and G so
now we have Q and G but I introduced
this new nuisance function which is
basically the condition alarm R - first
moment so it's again something we have
to estimate but it's still two
orthogonal so I can get this pretty poor
into the - 1 6 estimate of it but on top
of that I've actually required that you
know something that you didn't have to
know before and that is this artha
moment so that maybe is a little bit
knowing if you know the arc moment
that's great then you just go if I use
this that's it may be a little bit
annoying so what what can we do if we
don't know that well if you don't know
that there's a very similar moment
function you could use that I would say
well whatever call almost two orthogonal
so instead of saying that you know the
Arth moment we're just gonna make that
another nuisance function - and these
moments are two orthogonal with respect
to almost all of your paring all of your
partial derivatives but there are a
couple of partial derivatives that are
not that don't enjoy your Falcon ality
that's the pair between Q and you are
and the pair between G mu R so a couple
of pairings that don't satisfy without
finality and this mean and it's in -
what this means for us is that I need to
estimate you are at a faster rate so if
I can estimate in exactly and so exactly
what we need for this case is if I can
estimate mu R at an end to the minus
one-third rate and I can estimate
everything else at an end to the minus
one-sixth rate then I still get my
asymptotic normality
okay so we're still doing better than we
were before
where everything had to be end to minus
1/4 and particular I'll show you that
estimating you are a 10 so minus 1/3
rate is typically not hard it actually
gets easier when R is higher
okay so let's to demonstrate that let's
what specialize this to the the setting
of high dimensional linear new sense
we've been carrying round these nuisance
functions the apps and the G's I'm gonna
make them linear functions now but
potentially high dimensional one so ones
where I have tons of confounders and
that number can be growing with the
number of data points all right so now I
have the linear function X with
parameter beta naught and linear
function X with parameter gamma naught
entering into my equations and the
question you want to ask is how many
relevant confounders can we tolerate if
these I can't expect to estimate all
these parameters if they're they're all
relevant but if these functions are
sparse if the parameter vectors
themselves are sparse I can hope to
still do good estimation and get good
treatment effect estimates so for
instance I could use the lasso so I
could use a laugh so to estimate beta
naught and gamma naught what does that
give me it just typically gives me error
that looks like square root S log P over
N okay so what does that mean if I just
rely on zeroth order orthogonality if I
just use my typical these squares
moments that means I need s to grow to
shrink with log P so you can be bounded
a thought piaced boundary to shrink with
log P to get my root and asymptotic
normality so that's not great if we use
first order of thought finality where I
need only n to the minus 1/4 rates I can
actually let my sparsity grow so I could
if I'm in a setting where I actually
want to use nonlinear functions and I'm
doing bases expansions this lets my
sparsity grow at a rate of n to the
would n to the 1/2 or a log P so that's
that's good that's much better and I can
support much more complicated functions
that way now what we can show is that if
you use the second-order thoughtful
moments and particular estimates for
though all those nuisance functions that
I mentioned that you can actually get
you can actually get away with n to the
2/3 over log P instead of n to the 1/2
so this is how it works you're going to
estimate the the parameter vectors gamma
naught and Q naught Q naught here is a
linear combination of beta naught and
gamma naught
you're gonna estimate them both with the
lasso they're both sparse
you're gonna estimate the unknown
moments in a particular way you're going
to do some additional sample splitting
so you're gonna you're gonna take your
first stage sample which had endpoints
you're gonna break that into half you're
gonna fit the last so estimates on half
of it and then you're going to use the
the other half to estimate the second
and third moments in the following way
and it turns out that those satisfy all
of those convergence properties in
particular this is a end to the
one-third consistent and this is as I
said a faster rate and so if you plug
those in the choice of our I made in
this case three you know there's a
different there's a different set of
moments for different Orissa cars a
choice part of it made in this case is
three then you get your route out of
asymptotic normality now that I should
just note though that there's a
condition and the condition here is that
you're again violating Gaussian in some
way so in this case you have to have
excess kurtosis so this condition says
if you have excess kurtosis then this
will work then you'll get root in
asymptotic normality if you picked R
equals two then the condition is that
your skewness is not zero if you pick R
equals four you get another condition
depending on a different moment
okay so so we implemented this how we're
doing on time by the way oh sorry yeah
so they're bunch of other assumptions
here these are all just assumptions that
we picked that make the lasso work you
could use other things here too yeah
roughly anything I guess it makes the
lasso work there are a few other
technical conditions but these are not
really essential to the orthogonality
part of things so basically it means for
the confidence interval and high
dimensional linear regression you can
beat all the previous results if the
conditional distribution of the variable
I care about condition on others is not
Kelcey is that so that's that's what it
that's what it seems like and so we'll
come back to that too because I wonder
so we know there are known lower bounds
for for for doing this sort of thing but
those lower bounds all seem to assume
Gaussian entails yeah so I think that's
a really interesting question like can
you beat those over bounds like getting
out of Gaussian t
okay so okay we implemented this we're
trying to these are all so what I'm
gonna show you are all simulations but
they're trying to mimic this price
elasticity of demand setting so T is
representing our log price we're drawing
a tow from this discrete distribution
representing random discounts over that
base price and here to some results so
here I'm comparing the distribution of
oh and so I'm estimating theta zero here
that's my target I want it that's my
elasticity so I'm showing you the
distribution of my elasticity estimates
when I either use first order orthogonal
that's double machine learning or second
order ortho finality where the where the
nuisance is fit via the lasso and so in
this case the true value that was used
to generate the model is this blue line
is at the value three you can see here
that we have a lot of bias from the
first order so if our store goes on top
second orders on the bottom we're
getting a lot of bias and the bias is
actually an order of magnitude larger
than the variance
okay so it's like it's pretty
concentrated its creative concentrated
about the wrong value by employing the
second order in this case your variance
does increase somewhat but it does get
rid of your bias yeah oh yeah so I'm
following all the prescriptions of this
this theorem so X is are iid Gaussian
the Epsilon's are uniform in a range
minus Sigma to Sigma
they're up by the other
all right so here's another here's a
breakdown of bias and variance and so
this is basically what you expect you're
seeing that as your support size as the
you know number of relevant confounders
grows the bias of the first order
methods is growing pretty quickly
whereas the second order method is
growing in a very shallow way not that
much at all but on the other hand the
standard deviation of the first order is
pretty consistent whereas the standard
deviation of the second order is growing
and so there's a trade-off here and in
this case though the trade-off is still
in the favor of of second order so the
overall MSE is actually much higher for
the first order than the second-order as
your support size grows
so here's some plots from different
settings of N and P so before it was 5
and as of 5,000 P is 1000 here's an as
10,000 P is 1000 ever seen a very
similar picture here's NS 5,000 PS 2000
and you see a similar picture until at
this point there's some sort of crazy
numerical instability and the air shoots
out me do it to my six or it goes all
the plot we think this has to do with
the fact that you're when you solve that
second stage equation you can get values
that are actually very close to zero and
then if you're not doing anything to
control for that you can get arbitrarily
large estimates out so we're getting
some sort of instabilities when your
denominator in that second stage
estimate is near zero
okay here's bearing the noise level I
mentioned that epsilon was uniform - -
Sigma 2 Sigma so this is what happens as
you vary that noise level and I think I
just want to leave you with some
opportunities for future directions some
of which had already been have already
been surfaced in the conversation we've
had so far
so first or second order thought
orthogonal T how do we select optimal
moments or if not optimal improved
moments than the ones I gave you today
and how do you construct moments for
other causal inference models I'm mostly
focused on partially linear regression
for a orthogonality when are they
available I only really explored a
second-order here when can you do third
or fourth order and when are they useful
and how do we construct them we talked a
little bit about lower bounds there's
this very related literature on lasso D
biasing and we out of that literature
and some of the statistics that are sure
we actually have lower bounds for these
sorts of problems but they often assume
Gaussian 'ti of the covariance of all
the Kobe rates including in our case the
treatment variable so I think an
interesting question is can you beat
that lower bound if you have a non
Gaussian covariance and then of course
I'm really interested in applications to
other problems with mountain Gaussian
treatment residuals so let's leave these
ideas up for you all of you and
hopefully you'll have fun
[Applause]
so that this theory doesn't necessarily
depend on the target parameter being
identifiable as issue also primary even
though the motivation that's causal
inference so definitely so your moments
definite lead to identify the parameter
and so in some sense there's has to be
truth to the set of moments that so that
is identification does matter yeah so
like fair noise like the true causal
hasn't it has to be the truth that's
right
gracious I mean maybe wrong it seems
like this is solving these things in
practice might require some fairly large
tensor type of computation like this
oh well well it depends on how bigger
your parameters and our case are the
treatment effective o is a scalar that's
a very new scence oh well the Arneson
primary estimates are just like fit
lassos and you could you could
alternatively do something like fit
boosted regression tree is there all oh
so well okay so I should go I didn't
really talk about the nuisance
estimation that much but the reason why
we use these particular moments is
because essentially pulls the estimation
of the nuisance down to in the linear
case even in the nonlinear case to just
solving two regression problems and you
only care about actually a prediction
error you don't care about you don't
even care about parameter consistency
for these results and so to fit nuisance
as I'm sure what you'll do is you'll
regress Y on to X and you'll set whether
your sto into X and those are gonna give
you a nuisance estimates and do it using
your favorite regressor so it could be
boosted decision trees or random forests
it could be the lasso and those that's
what you plug in for your nuisance
estimates these cubic terms on to minus
X Y oh yeah yeah those those don't
matter so those only matter the moment
the moment actually only matters for the
solution of theta
you don't salt you don't minimize this
moment function with respect to any of
the other parameters you just plug in
whatever estimate you want of those
parameters that has to be good you know
good in the sense of reminds more 2 k
plus 2
so your favorite auxiliary that way of
estimating those things which is I think
one of the advantage of the double
machine learning written work to begin
with which is that has this
plug-and-play feature
you just easy yeah and then you only use
these to fit theta and theta this is
linear and theta in this case that's re
good so when you saw suffering them when
you fit beta zero period guess beta zero
you brought in the lasso on the model
with both beta and beta zero but not
that beta 0 which is sort of reasonably
consistent or you could do that and
that's and if I use slightly different
moment equations that would probably the
thing you do so the reason why I reaper
ammeter eyes this is Q 0 equal to this
linear combination is that instead of
doing that I'm just actually gonna
regress Y on to execute so that I don't
have to separately keep a fate as Europe
from there around I'm just gonna fit I
do the regression of Y onto X okay that
to Hat yeah exactly
that's yeah to reasonable because of
that
but you could do what you said and in
the general case and that's fine too
our questions
so for CF you able to get yeah yes in
Chile yeah um yeah so as long as it's as
long as it's fine as long as it's fixed
and finite well you're not to say we
don't change it you just pick K any
fixed numbers but then you'll get that
you overcome your kegels - yeah yeah but
in practice choosing more than k k
larger than two can be can be useful
practice asymptotic ly you're gonna get
the same thing but in finite samples it
makes it
okay if there is no other question we go
for lunch